guess what we have today
uh the great news is you don't actually
have to guess and judging by the title
of the video and the fact of the
thumbnail i'm holding two green iphones
you guys know that we're unboxing the
new green iphones today these are the
new iphone 13 so we have an iphone 13
mini in the is there a specific name for
this green green
it says green this is alpine green so
this has an actual name it's very
special type of green so we've got both
of the phones unboxed we've also got an
apple watch band this is the silicon
loop see this is where things get
confusing this color is called
eucalyptus which looks very similar to
the other two so we've got green alpine
eucalyptus are you also eucalyptus
you're also eucalyptus okay good to know
so we do have consistency in the band
and the cases okay so let's unbox the
iphone 13 pro first can't wait to see
this alpine green i feel like this is
kind of very similar to the what was it
iphone 11
oh whoa
okay if you're a green fan like this is
definitely something that you're gonna
be into like check that out so this
green also looks pretty similar to the
iphone 11 they did have the iphone 11 in
a very similar green color hoping that i
do have one of the green ones so i can
show you guys the comparison if not i
know a friend that lives nearby so i
might have to go hunt them down so i can
see their phone color comparison here we
have
the iphone 13 mini
in the green as well i love the mini
phone i think it's really great
oh
[Music]
this is a nice color this matches my
shirt quite well so i like this because
it's like a more deep kind of a green
color obviously you can tell this has
the frosted glass back where this has
the more just all glass back so there's
not the frosted finish but this does
have the frosted finish on the camera so
it's kind of just a little bit of a
reversal this green is actually very
nice like i'm not a huge fan of the
color green but like if you are this is
great which is ironic because my
favorite color combination is camouflage
so you would think that this would be a
color that i would like but it's got to
be mixed in with other color greens and
browns for me to be into it so we also
have the new eucalyptus cases and the
apple watch band let's open this band up
and check it out i have been wanting to
switch out my apple watch band and i was
so excited because there's actually a
flamingo pink one of the
uh loop bands oh god what it's called
it's like the knitted one the braided
solo loop i was
i was saying knitted so i definitely
have that on the way and i'm super hyped
about it here
is the eucalyptus
oh this looks great so i did end up
getting the gold apple watch uh here we
go
i originally ordered the starlight and
then i kept seeing the gold and i was
like that is so beautiful like i need
that one so i gave my mom my starlight
one and i
got myself the gold i've had on this
milanese loop for so long this is not a
good band to work out with i have been
but it's definitely not ideal like this
this feels so much lighter now wow i'm
moving and grooving let me go get my
green apple watch
here we go
the gang is all here so this is actually
wow that is actually a different green
color the eucalyptus is different it's
kind of got a little more
blue kind of a tone so this is the green
apple watch that came out
last year and this is one of the green
watch bands so you can actually see
there is a color difference the new
apple watch band eucalyptus color has
more of a blue kind of hue to it let's
open up the cases and put our cases on i
just love that these all match like look
at that that's beautiful here's the
iphone 13
pro i'm just gonna say like i
i've been loving my iphone 13. like i
have no complaints did forget about
cinematic mode until we used it the
other day and i was like oh my god that
looks incredible
i forgot about it you have an iphone 13
you forgot about cinematic mode here's a
reminder okay iphone 13 mini
let's put you in your new home
in case
look at you absolutely stunning
the apple watch band matches so
perfectly
so i like that this green
still really matches these new phones
very well it's one thing that i do like
is the fact that the apple watch
matches the actual apple watch matches
these greens and it looks really really
good so they did do a great job of that
making sure that all of the green bands
and the green watch all kind of color
coordinated together it's like look
these all look pretty good now let's
take them outside for some you know
slo-mo b-roll
[Music]
went out and found ourselves an iphone
11 in green to do a comparison between
the green from the 11 to the 13s it's
pretty similar it does seem like it has
a little bit more of like a bluish kind
of hint which is kind of similar to the
bluish hint that they kind of put into
the new cases
like i forgot how small the camera bumps
were on the 11. that's crazy to just
kind of look back to be like started
from the bottom now we're here
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching hope
you guys enjoyed this first look at the
new green iphone 13s these are available
right now so you can order them and i'm
very excited about this because i do
feel like there are some people who
really wished that they did the iphone
13 in a green especially to match the
new apple watch so if you were one of
those people that wished and didn't
already buy an iphone it is your lucky
day i'd love to hear from you guys in
the comments below which iphone color is
your favorite and if there's a color
that they haven't made just yet or you
wish they would make again be sure to
share that in the comments and if you
haven't already subscribed please hit
subscribe hit the bell to be notified
when i post new videos because it's
apple season so you better believe i'll
have some reviews for you guys coming up
very very soon
[Music]